welcome to film courage this is episode
163 I'm Karen warden and I'm David
Brandon you can find our archives on
itunes movie garage as well as film
curds calm today we are speaking with
filmmaker mike stats whose documentary
don't change the subject takes a comedic
look at suicide hmmm don't change the
subject is a beautiful film on a serious
subject that will surprise you it's a
documentary about about suicide you know
it might be something that would scare
many people however might take you on a
journey with don't change the subject
that is more of a bowl look at life what
was and bringing to the surface many
things people don't want to discuss what
he does it in sort of a safe light way
where you just want to keep watching the
movie yeah he does an amazing job
celebrating the memories of those who
have passed on and also the personal
accounts of others who've attempted
suicide and lived to tell about it
leaving the viewer with a glimpse of
what makes life worth living hmm don't
change the subject peppers in humor on
to keep it from being morse and tragic
still giving respect to those who have
passed on by their own will please
welcome to film courage mike studs
welcome Mike there we go I'm glad to be
here you guys do a great job so glad to
be a part of the show oh thank you much
thank you Mike thank you well in order
to talk about the documentary Mike
please tell us about your upbringing
since this is a through line throughout
the entire film how did suicide enter
your life well when I was a kid my mom
suffered from the clinical depression
and she was an actress and a writer
herself and she was pretty sick the last
couple of years of her life she was hot
in and out of hospitals and and and she
ended her life just before my 12th
birthday and then years later a woman
named Judith moved in who was my
stepmother and was a great stepmom and
and we knew each other for 30 years or
so
and in the last year of Judas life for
the first time she started talking about
the fact that her father too had killed
himself and not only her father killed
himself but it was in very similar
circumstances at an age close to the age
I was when my mom died and I thought if
we weren't talking about suicide then
then no one was talking about suicide
that it's such a taboo subject that even
in our own family a family who was able
to talk to each other about other things
it it just didn't come up and it's just
never did it was never the right time
you never knew how to broach the subject
and and that made me want to make this
film and not not only to get the ball
rolling and hopefully help some other
people to talk about suicide but also to
honor those that we lost to honor my
mother and to honor Judith's father cow
both of them were very vibrant life
filled interesting life of the party
type of people i think that there's a
misconception sometimes although someone
killed themselves or someone suffer from
depression so that means that they were
always really down and and you know sort
of shut away and that and that was not
the case and that's not the case with a
lot of people we lose so i wanted to
make a film to honor them to honor their
lives and honor who they were and not
just dwell on the last day the last
hours that that's not what it's about
when someone dies a suicide yeah and
your film was very apparent it shows
that very much that you do celebrate
these lives in a very light weight
although it's a tragic subject but you
do um I think leave the viewer with some
sense of hope while watching the film um
you seem comfortable discussing your
mother's passing I realized it did
happen a while ago but you know so many
people have been taught to cloak family
secrets you know to hide them but
there's the same we're only as sick as
our secrets when you tell people about
your mother's passing what is the
typical reaction well people still it's
amazing people I had someone apologized
to me a week ago my mother died 32 years
ago 33 years ago and
someone made a reference in passing that
people do they said I oh my God if I
don't you know finish this project I'm
gonna kill myself and then sent me an
email saying I'm so sorry you know I
can't believe I said that and that's
considerate and I understand it but you
know I think that people are afraid
you're going to break if they say
anything that if they you know that you
know who knows how Mike's gonna react of
course it was a tragedy of course it was
you know a very tough time in my life
but but I want to talk about it and you
know everybody goes through difficult
experiences everyone faces challenges in
their life and and i think that people
shouldn't fear i find so often when I
talk to people who have had suicide in
their family or or maybe attempted
themselves that after seeing the movie
they sort of breathe a sigh of relief
like good finally we're talking about
finally they can use the film as a
jumping off point to just talk and
clearly air and not and not be so
concerned about like what if I say their
own word what if I you know what if I
sends the person that I'm talking to you
know my advice to someone if you know
someone that's going through it is of
course be sensitive about it of course
you know understand that everybody has
different reactions but talk to them
about it if you have questions or you
have concerns about them or anything
talk to them about I bet they will want
to talk about it and you're right it is
families especially are good at hiding
secrets you know families are they our
extra-special good at at figuring out
ways not to talk about stuff and and
that makes it so much worse and so much
more of a challenge as as as strange
thoughts sort of accumulated and
misinformation and and and people you
know let things build in their minds it
gets much worse than it would be if you
just just talk about it you know Michael
I'm wondering sort of aside from you you
know your mom's death you know has def
been very present and you're in your
entire life you know because for me I
kind of grew up where I didn't really
have to face death really until the last
two or three years and all of a sudden
I've really had to face it quite a bit
and I'm just wondering for you you know
has it come up quite a bit throughout
your entire life well I'm sorry I'm
sorry that you've been going through
that
that's how difficult that must be but I
I have had it around and I think
interestingly for me my mother's death
helped me to understand in a way how how
fragile our existence is on this earth
that that you can't just say well do it
tomorrow I'll do it in 10 years or you
know you don't know that that you're
always going to have an infinite amount
of time with people or you're gonna ever
an infinite amount of time on this
planet so I think that my mom's death
helped just help me to understand that
that you should enjoy the days that
you're here i would say that in my life
a death has probably been no more
prevalent than in a lot of people's
lives but while we were making this film
judith my stepmom was dying of cancer
and so she was actually in hospice care
during the entire time that we were
filming and that really helped to inform
the film as well um that seeing her what
she was going through seeing what was
important to her seeing her want to talk
about not only her father but about
family life in general um and and seeing
how much life meant to her was a good
reminder that you really need to to to
do what you need to do that you need
that don't put it off if you have
something to say or you have something
to do and in my case it was making this
movie do it you know that doesn't mean
you can just drop everything and start
tomorrow but make plans make it happen
so I think in some ways judith was a
real driving force behind this movie and
thankfully she even though she was in a
lot of pain in her last month she
followed very closely what we were doing
she asked about what we were shooting
she has to wear who we were interviewing
how it was going I'm she did a series of
interviews with us as well for the movie
and and she got to see the first rough
cut of the movie three days before she
died it would have been the last thing
that she saw the last movie um that she
saw so and she loved him you know haha
that's really powerful I'm wondering
what was your takeaway when you found
out from judith that her father had died
under very similar circumstances as your
mother I mean did you feel that there
was some type of spiritual reason that
she had come into your life or I know
you know i don't i don't know i don't
know if it was kismet or not um but i'm
very glad she did come into my life and
um she taught me she taught me many many
great things and i think that she
learned them she had a great sort of
patience and a warm accepting of life
that came at her and I allow myself to
get stressed out and caught up in a lot
of things and I think that her life
experiences um and a lot of the
challenges that which she went through
when she was young um helped form her as
an adult as a very balanced adult and
that helped me a lot as a person so so I
don't know whether it was meant to be
but I'm really glad that judith was a
part of my life very nice yeah you know
so many indie filmmakers they want to
make horror films with teens running
around chasing the woods and their
underwear and you've you've chosen to do
so I go to those skills you go that's
your next one but um so many people
don't want to talk about suicide for
whatever reason their own thoughts of it
that they don't want to expose religious
reasons whatever sure let's go back to
why you felt you need to make this film
that would probably scare a lot of
people but it doesn't want you see it
but in theory yep oh it scares everybody
yeah I mean we you know as you know the
article that I wrote for your site at
says you know we managed to sort of
scare off everyone we scare people who
don't want to talk about suicide and
then people who are involved the suicide
community are scared that what if we say
the wrong thing so so yeah we made a
film that absolutely everyone can find a
reason not to watch um but the nice
thing about it was I wanted to make a
film in a sense I wanted to make a film
that I would have wanted to see when I
was kid I'm after my mom died and I
wanted to make a film for everyone out
so everyone in the suicide community who
would cringe at being called a part of
the suicide community um that I was a
punky odd weird kid um and I know that a
lot of filmmakers out there perhaps
might fit into that description and
I made this move i'm sure not you guys
you're now normal you know stat you know
very young republicans club exactly so i
made this film for everyone who feels
like an oddball and a freak and and
feels like they're the only one feeling
these odd feelings i made this film for
a kid sitting in a dorm room who maybe
is having some trouble and feels like
nobody's gone through an experience i
think they've gone through one of the
things we're doing with the movie is is
getting it out there to colleges getting
it out there to two people two teens do
to anyone we can it's almost sort of
handing it off on the street to to just
I my dream is someone finds one on a bus
stop goes home watches it and thinks
well maybe I should stick around you
know and I never made the movie thinking
that we're going to make money off of
this and i never i did not make the move
you thinking well we're though this is
gonna be the big one we're going to get
you know everyone's going to get famous
you don't make it suicide a funny
suicide documentary i'm looking for fame
but but i did make it for a kid who who
does not respond to what i would call
sort of the typical movie about suicide
which tends to have sort of soft
lighting and low speech and and I'm not
mocking it it it is a very valuable tool
for a lot of people to have that you
know very therapeutic you know talk
through a type thing either that or the
or there are films that just show a lot
of bodies which I don't love either um I
made it for the other person you know I
made it I made it for the person who who
feels that no one's quite like them in
the world and and I've not like them
because everybody's an individual but I
do know what it's like to feel that way
um and and it's I think the great thing
now is that you can make movies like
that that this movie didn't cost a half
a million dollars or a million dollars
or you know that because digital video
is so good and editing systems and
everything else that that I don't know
that I could have made this movie 15
years ago um and and and I think that
more and more and I see on your site
obviously with many of the filmmakers
I'm with you guys who I know you have a
film premiering next month i believe yes
we have something to say and now
finally we have the tools to say and so
I can make a movie saying hey if I reach
you know if only 10,000 people see this
then there may be a thousand people who
are really affected by it and maybe
there's a few who actually stick around
and that to me is a good reason to make
it Moby follow you know net I'm sorry up
oh sorry well as I say it's great too
because you're right so many people have
trouble reaching out especially to
because what they is it against the law
to threaten suicide or they'll arrest
you or put hey it's not usually a legal
thing there are a lot of different
reasons people think a lot of people
think of if I'm suicidal than I'm weak
if I'm feeling depressed because the
pressure is a really bad term to start
with because people people think of
being depressed as oh my football team
lost I'm so depressed or my you know I'm
having trouble with my girlfriend I'm
feeling depressed that's not depression
depression is is a long-term disease
that that is just as real as cancer or
broken legs or anything else and and it
is something that that can debilitate
you I mean my mother could not get out
of bed for four weeks and months at a
time when she was finally sort of
nearing the end of her life so I think
there are a lot of people who there are
a lot of people who mean well who tell
someone who is depressed or maybe even
feeling suicidal hey you don't buck up
like it'll be okay I've been depressed
right I've had I've had blues I felt bad
you just got to work through it you know
and that just makes him feel worse like
you know know that you don't compare
yourself to them talk to them listen to
them um you know and understand that
they're going through something real
over and over when I've been out at a
lot of colleges talking to students and
over and over I am amazed at how few
students understand the depressions
disease and that that that what they're
feeling is something that a lot of
people feel on to some degree at some
point of their life again they feel like
they're the only one feeling this way
that they're weak and that if they reach
out that somehow they're they're
reflecting their own weakness right and
there are all sorts of other reasons I
mean yes religion can certainly play
into it which we touch on in the movie a
lot of people feel that you know just
even addressing it that you know
that this is a sin if and and a lot of
people also have very difficult
challenging feelings if they have
someone they know that dot of suicide
because they feel well maybe they went
to hell and and one of the things we
talked about of the movie is that even
the Catholic Church now has changed the
stance it is no longer a mortal sin in
the Catholic Church which is important
because my stepmothers father Cal they
were Catholics he was a pillar in their
church and they wouldn't bury him in
that in the churchyard and and it was
treated as a shameful thing that he did
and that was devastating to the family
and really pushed a lot of silence so
there are a lot of things they're also
cultural you know a lot of cultures you
know have a lot of difficulty again with
that that that sense weakness or taboo
and and so well I'm trying to do with
the movie and not just me what a lot of
great organizations out there working to
to fight you know against suicide and to
and to help support people who've gone
through the thing are saying is that
there's absolutely no shame to feeling
this way but talk to someone you know
whether it's talking to friends whether
it's talking to family about the way you
feel or if you don't want to talk to
them 800 273 talk as the national
suicide hotline you are not a crazy
person if you call a suicide hotline
they will just listen to you they're not
going to come hunt you down there
they're going to listen they're going to
try and help you they're going to try
and hook you up someone who might be
able to help you if you want that help
um and if you know someone that that is
feeling this way you can also call that
suicide online again 800 273 talk which
is on our website as well you can call
them and ask them how can I help my
friend what can I say to them how do I
approach this can you help me where can
I get them resources and they will get
those for you um if if if if we can do
one thing this movie and I and a very
gratifying thing is we already have with
a fair amount of folks it is to break
down that wall and say there is no shame
in feeling bad and then feeling
depressed whether it's for a night
whether it's for a week whether it's for
ten years and that it's real and that
you are going through some
very real um that if you had cancer or
if you broke your arms or if you were in
a car accident you at the hospital
everyone would say oh my god you know
how can I help you what's going on how
are you feeling you know but when you
feel depression a lot of times people
will really treat it with somewhat of
derision you know they'll they'll though
either say buck up or worse you know say
well you just you need to get over it
you know you need you'd stops feeling
sorry for yourself depression is not
feeling sorry for yourself and that what
we're trying to get across with the
movie sure be grateful for what you have
and things like that yeah and all that's
good i mean positive bugs are all good
i'm not saying that you're not wrong to
want to say positive things to someone
but you are wrong to think that well if
they just walked around the block like
they would be okay you know that it
would go up okay like you know if you
just walk down the block your cancer
might go away like that's that's the
equivalent plug-in cancer um when you're
thinking of depression and and people do
recover from cancer and people do
recover from depression but before you
say it think what I say this to someone
with what you know what society accepts
as you know a very serious disease oh
well take F in your damn sure I get
better right right well I think too for
women it's easier to admit to depression
than it is for men right because for men
it's like oh he's weak or what's wrong
with him yeah alright so there's a big
stigma for men I think we're as a lot of
men don't want to get help for it is
that right yeah and more women attempt
suicide but more men succeed at and I
believe and again I'm not a psychiatrist
and I'm not a statistician but my
understanding is that one of the leading
groups who actually succeed at suicide
are white men in their 40s and 50s in a
lot of like Montana Arizona Idaho in I
somewhere isolated area with access to
guns less access to someone to talk to
and and who may fall into that category
of you know I am I've always done
everything myself and so I'm not gonna
I'm not going to talk to someone about
this um and you know that it affects all
different age groups it's a huge killer
of young people it's the number two
killer of college-age kids
and it's it's up there i believe it's
close to surpassing even alcohol-related
deaths so so it it runs the spectrum but
yeah there i think that there are a lot
of men out there him again you know I
you know I'm not weak but they would
rather die than talk sir no what I'm
saying is talk hey you know you could
you can dilate it let's talk now let's
talk for today and it's not going to be
today is one that since that's out there
like you know what stick around give it
some time because over and over I talked
a lot of people who attempted and over
and over they said that that after they
got past that attempt they wanted so
much to be here that there is this time
of crisis this few hour period where
you're in severe crisis and you think I
you don't think I want to die what you
think is I want to end the pain right
and and and if you could talk to someone
just then if you can just make it
through those few hours you will make it
like it it won't all get better in the
morning won't be just go away but but
what you're feeling will pass and
there's a lot of things out there to
help you therapy and a lot of good any
presents now when my mom was suffering
from depression in the drugs sucked day
and they helped kill her they were it
was she was on the equivalent of a mix
of its it's not these drugs but if they
do the equivalent thing of ritalin
ambien and xanax like just a sort of
cocktail of it right which is a terrible
mix of stuff but now the drugs are
really good um you don't you have to
maybe try more than one they may not the
first one may not be perfect for you but
but they really help you know and if
you're really suffering there's again
there's no shame there's no stigma in
taking medication you know you take
blood pressure medication or you take
you know medication for for other things
why would it why would it be worse you
know to take it for your mind the most
important thing you have you know so so
yeah I have no idea what the question
even was I just read a long talk to you
about the colleges so how are you
getting booked to speak at these
colleges are you preparing a press kit
and reaching out are you saying them
screeners of the film yeah we you know
everything we did that this movie was
done with blind you know
and plowing forward you know we didn't
know and I say we because there was a
lot of producers involved in this movie
it's not just me I mean you know there
certainly is there are days where it's
me sitting here at this table and typing
away but but I really have to
acknowledge a lot of producers you know
Fiona Walsh and Matt EEMA but
particularly Charlie r xik is a guy
who's a good friend of mine he's in the
movies the musician who created all of
the music and we follow him but
Charlie's been unbelievable resource and
just searching out contacts for all the
colleges really going out just plucking
email after email putting it together in
a database standing at we send out an
initial kind of email blast saying you
know one page or saying hey here's what
the movie is here's where you can see
the preview week we had a good website
up with a lot of stuff on it reviews
from critics you know positive reviews
from from early groups that had seen it
and and our preview and information
about the movie so we sent on an initial
blast and anybody who responded to that
blast then we said okay if you want to
see it we had a secure online site where
they could then go watch the movie
themselves to make sure is this
appropriate for our college um and it
was great you know when we got a lot of
really good responses and and it helped
the thing with this movie is if you see
it you'll book it if you see it you'll
like it um and until you see it you'll
think you're not gonna your think oh you
know what I you know I might be
depressing or tonight so I goodnight I
hear over and over oh yeah I'm sure you
guys weren't guilty of that it sets it
in our locker you know absolutely but I
just watched it and it changed our mind
yeah yeah and so so with the college's
it was to our benefit to get them to see
it and once we did then we set it up
where you know some of the colleges were
would just you know screen without me
there but some of them also had me come
out and speak and and I would do a
presentation before and then at QA after
and and at some schools i would also go
into class i like to go in and lecture
in classes whether it's film or
psychology or whatever i used to do some
teaching at UCLA and and and i really
enjoy
that back and forth I really enjoy even
if someone says oh well yeah I don't
think this is right or I don't think
you're you know we got plenty of
responses back because it wasn't just
colleges we also got in touch with a lot
of mental health organizations thousands
of them and some got back and said yes
thank God you know someone's doing this
movie great we'd love to show it another
said this is an appropriate screw you
you know there we did get some negative
reactions from from pretty the preview
and things and I'd get into a discussion
with them you know we get okay well what
is it about the film that you know let
me know if I'm wrong let me know where I
should correct myself what am I saying
that's that's incorrect and and again
usually when they saw the movie they
might not booked it some would some
wouldn't but used but usually they would
not be as negative as they were off the
initial concept like just the idea that
we could use humor but to me it's just
too much to watch you have to make a
movie no matter what your movie is and
there will be those who disagree with me
but I feel that there has to be or in
the way that I like to approach projects
I feel there has to be something some
level of entertainment even in the
toughest subject um otherwise it's a
lecture and I know there are wonderful
wonderful documentaries out there that
are you know non-black riots um but but
I do think you owe it to the I you're
saying like look I get it this is a
tough subject to talk about so let's
find a way to frame it that I can keep
you involved and even if you look at the
way that I structure the movie itself if
I've done my job correctly we start with
some humor and kind of get you in and we
get you a little comfortable we get you
into the bath and and you know let's
just settle it a little bit and then and
then it gets a little more challenging
than there are interviews that that you
know might make you cry or or or might
you know stir up some stuff inside you
but then we back off and give you a
little more comedy and a little more
lighter stuff and then we kind of come
back we try and we push there's a point
in the film about two-thirds of the way
through that I always think when I go
see the movie and I've seen it now
hundreds of times and certainly dozens
of times with audiences where I think if
they can make it through this like
there's one section that's pretty
challenging that has a couple of
challenging interviews and uh and uh
maybe a slightly unsettling performance
the commedia performance with
staging my mom's death and I'm like if
you can make it through those then
you're fine then you're home free you
know like now there's nothing but comedy
coming of the another comedy an
uplifting stuff you know and I just
think that you owe it to your audience
to help them with the experience to not
hammer them over the head so hard that
that that they can't stand up at the end
of it you know and that doesn't mean you
you you make light of the subject um I
just I want I'm still going to see a
movie I'm still watching a movie and if
I want a lecture I'll ask for a lecture
but I want to be told what to think then
I'll ask you for that but hopefully in
this movie I'd give you a little leeway
to to to find your own feelings and I
have gotten responses from people who
who have walked me through like their
emotional state like in the movie and
they're like you know it was really
funny and I was really happy to be there
and then I was really sad and I thought
screw you Mike why have you done this to
me that was really after you get and you
know it hopefully I made the film hoping
that you'll take the whole ride and by
the end it's worth it um and because i
don't know like if you watch half the
movie what'd you get out of it i have to
assume you're gonna watch the whole
thing the funniest thing that i've run
into at some colleges is and i can't
imagine this is true but maybe the world
has changed uh it said you have a
shorter version of movie our students
won't watch an hour and 37 minutes only
an hour and 37 I'm like really um you
know like like a student can't possibly
watch more than 45 minutes of anything
and to me that's a sad state if that's
true I don't think it is but but but I
have gotten that request and the answer
is no if you can't look into an hour at
37 you don't need to bother with my
movie I mean Mike you're talking about
screening on colleges can't on college
campuses for students and that's at the
top of the show you mentioned that you
made this film specifically with that
kid in the dorm room who was going to
come across this and possibly this film
could impact their life you know has the
film screened for that student I mean is
there any kind of success story you can
share with us absolutely i mean you know
i think one of the nicest success
stories mean you know all stories are
continuing so you know but at least at
this point one of the one of the most
gratifying stories and the end
and there have been quite a few is
actually in the movie would be Linda
it's not a student but Linda who is the
who lost her daughter um and she was a
professional painter and was not able to
to paint and and though i will give away
something in the movie i don't think i
think you can still enjoy it with um she
was in a pretty tough state when she
came into the interview with us and i
think the interview helps maybe nudge
her in a slightly different direction
where she then was able to get back to
painting and was able to paint her
daughter and i think was able to kind of
get back into our life and I I and and I
know she's doing really well now i don't
in any way trying to take credit for
that that's Linda working through a
tough issue and Linda really being open
to to to getting back into a life right
so I'm not saying that we did it but I
think that even she would say that we
helped we we we helped a little bit and
and I have had many many people get in
touch with me who said I had one person
that I know you said her family had
struggled with suicide and had suicide
in the family and they had never talked
about it and she said that after after
the movie she talked to her her mother
and brought up the fact that she'd seen
the movie and the mother then talked for
an hour and a half straight about the
suicides and their family at all these
things and it and the whole family
started to talk to each other and they
were engaging in ways that they never
had and her mother said to her well you
know I wouldn't have talked about this
but you kept going on and on about this
movie and my friend said mom all I said
was I saw a movie about suicide and come
and and even if that's what we're doing
even if you hate our movie and you just
say I saw a movie about tuesday that I
hate and now it's for as a conversation
you know great so I think that you know
it's it is the responses that I've
gotten from students and also from
mental health professionals who who
we've also spurred a lot of debate
within large groups that deal with grief
groups and suicide survival and all
those kind of things we've we've spurred
some good debate where some people say
you can't have a movie where you where
you talk about how someone attempted
suicide which we do you know someone
talks about jumping off the bridge and
you can't have a movie whether it's
humor and you can't have a movie where
there's an animation
even for one second that put it someone
puts a gun to their head and I should
say in the movie there are no dead
bodies and there are no there are no you
know gruesome scenes which which often
accompany these movies and I agree that
there's you should never glamorize
suicide and we don't but but there's
something called suicide contagion which
the media deals with them with which
people in the mental health field deal
with and so there's a lot of debate over
what you can say how you can say it
always think and I think that our movie
has been shown to a lot of groups and a
lot of leaders of these groups and has
spurred a lot of talk and debate and
have spurred talk in some of those
groups that maybe we need to re-examine
how we're approaching this because my
question is of course you need to of
course you need to treat the subject
with respect and you should never ever
glamorize suicide but you also need to
draw in people to watch your movie and
if you're making movies or videos that
no one is watching you're not helping
anyone and I had a psychologist as the
head of a large department at a
university say to me in his view and
this is his view not mine but he said I
think in some ways you know the people
in my business are causing more problems
than then helping um that there's so
much fear of saying the wrong thing that
nothing's getting said and that's
contributing to people's deaths so so I
hope that I hope in some way we're we're
sparing at this debate even if the
debate in the end the decision is a
movie like Mike's should never be shown
that's okay at least if that discussion
goes back and forth you know well going
back to the movie now you talk about
what is it diaz de los Muertos the Day
of the Dead yeah you did it Josie oh
okay so and you say in there it's
interesting according to the day of the
dead they say we sort of died three
times once when your heart stops twice
when they bury us in the ground and then
third when the last person we know dies
who cannot retell stories of us yes and
I thought that part was very interesting
because um you know it shows you and
your sister talking about your mom and
and and relieving some of those memories
but of the families that you've met that
have lost someone or lost friends how
many people sort of bury this person in
a box in a room and keep all their stuff
and then never go back to it and then
how many people share memories and laugh
and say I remember so and so would have
loved this yeah I I mean I really
encourage people to do that did de los
muertos to me is one of the best
holidays out there the idea is honoring
people who've come before us telling
funny stories about them sharing their
lives you put up a big altar and you put
all sorts of stuff on it you know you
you you put pictures of people you love
but you also put out like the food they
like the booze they like to drink
cigarettes they smoke the idea is you're
inviting them back to a party right so
you you you gather up everybody and then
you know everybody has different
traditions the tradition we have and we
have a pretty big you have a dead party
every year that grows over here is that
we go around and people tell funny
stories about the people they'd lost
attended and there's no disrespect in
those stories but it is you know someone
told the story about how his grandmother
lived to be 96 she smoked her whole life
in the last two years of her life she
quit smoking because she was so senile
she forgot she smoked right and it was
just a funny story of her and the
cigarettes right you know like like that
he remembers his grandmother and smoking
and shed and the warmth that he felt you
know they are right so so that this
movie was made as a day of the dead
altar we took everyone that that means
something to us all those who passed
before and we'd built an altar to them
and we took and for me it's also an
altar to my mother who loved music
comedy dance right so in this movie is
music comedy dance and there is my
mother's picture at the top of the altar
and we honor at the end of the movie
certainly everyone and to me that's what
you do to break this stigma you you talk
about the lives of these people and why
you love them and why you care about
them right and and you you share their
living sort of anima right and and and
you don't put them away in a box and
you're right in the movie we actually
literally have boxes I have you know six
boxes that had everything my mom ever
roped and pictures and all these things
and and I was looking through them for
the first time my dad had had them away
in a garage and I had not seen them
since I was kid and I not listen to
tapes of my mother's voice since she had
died and so I guess metaphorically and
literally we were taking mom you know
parts of mom's life back out of these
boxes and letting them live and letting
them breathe and
and I cannot stress enough how cathartic
it will be for you if you whether you've
lost someone to suicide or whether
you've lost them to anything else
whether they're just not with you now to
to open up those boxes look at those
pictures remember the funny stories
share them call up your family call up
your friends talk about whoever it is
you lost right on let them live again
through you you through your stories and
through the movies that we make right we
you you bring these people back to life
they're here they're part of you and and
soon we're not going to be here either
and I hope someone's around to tell my
story you know I hope someone's around
to tell you tell my wife story todo to
tell my family story yeah and I can't
think of a better way to honor people
than to share a laugh I'm all about my
whole life has been you know I've
written comedy and directed comedy and
been around it in theater and all these
things my whole life and so in my world
that's how you express yourself and
that's why I approach the film this way
I can only look at things through that
lens I I and and and I think that it's
helped it helped me to cope when my mom
died it's helped me through other
difficult times and and I imagine and
talking to you guys and also reading
your stuff and hearing you talk I know
you're sort of the same way and I hope
that you know and when you're talking
about having lost people recently I hope
that you're sharing those those there's
positive things about them it's none of
my business but but i but I you know I
encourage people because this movie a
really important thing about this movie
is it's not about suicide it's about
communication um it's about whatever it
is that you're afraid of whatever it is
that you just think that you if you say
it it'll be too scary right and it's
about moving past that I had a friend
who his parents went through a difficult
divorce he said this movie could have
just as easily been about 24 about the
silence that surrounds that right um and
and and it is like to me I have so many
flaws but one thing I'm not afraid to do
is talk about stuff I like it I find it
see I'm a crazy person so I like dead
like the darker the scarier the more I
like it
the more it's interesting to talk about
to me and that's how I you know in when
I'm especially when I was in New York
but um my comedy came from death and
mental illness and suicide and all those
things because I was naming what scares
me that's what comedy is it's it's a way
to name that scary thing and once you
name it everyone last they're laughing
is supporting the idea that they feel
the same way like oh yeah I was scared
of that too right um so so yes that
incredibly long answer would be yes
people do put it put other people away
in boxes and please don't open up the
boxes no I want to take a sort of
supernatural term for a second because
I'm very attracted to that a book that's
of interest to me is dr. Edith Fiore's
the unquiet dead know if you've ever
read you can google her on on YouTube
fascinating baby so she talks about
death being like we shed this overcoat
and we take on another form what she
calls a sort of an energy matrix and and
that many people who have you know had
emotional pain while living and then
they die still need to stick around on
this earthly plane to sort of figure out
what it was that was troubling them um
so of the people that you've talked to
did anybody have any kind of afterlife
interaction with family or friends that
had passed away as a result of suicide
uh not that I know of but you know I
think that there are a lot of people I
mean I know Linda particularly what the
woman I was talking about earlier felt a
very strong still connection to her
daughter and felt I think that's many of
our feelings were somewhat similar to
what you're talking about I know that
that certainly people i've talked to
feel a closeness with the person they've
lost or the people that they'd lost and
that in more than just a well you know
we we remember them type way but but a
real connection and you know I I I did
not dig as deeply into that in the in
the film but I think that that I whether
or not whether or not it's a it's an
actual electromagnetic connection or
whether it's just their DNA in your body
you know you are these people I mean I
am
so they go my mother is a big part of me
I mean more than just a you know memory
sense you know we were built from them
right we're built from other people and
you can't get around that so so yeah I
do i do think that there is certainly an
interconnectedness you know with us all
and that and that you know hopefully
reaching out and sharing with each other
just draws that closer you know that and
keeps us from dividing away from each
other and pushing away from each other
so you know yeah I mean yes I think
they're say i would certainly subscribe
to the idea that somehow we're all
pretty connected you know i'm not sure i
don't really understand how it is but my
mic you know you're from san diego um
you know you said on your facebook page
that you've watched junior seau yeah
play play football in high school you
follow Kevin you know followed his
career when he was at USC and then
obviously you know he played
professionally for many years in San
Diego as a charger the news broke this
week you know obviously that I mean you
know his suicide breaks this week and
obviously that hits home for you with
that with that connection you have to
him can you share maybe some of your
feelings and and some of the thoughts
that maybe we aren't seeing the media
cover well I think the thing that
fascinates me the most is is that people
seem to need him to have died because of
the concussions he suffered in football
that and that may well be true you know
that I'm not disputing that science and
that may well have contributed to
whatever mental state that he was in
when he died but I guess what interests
me is why why do we need that so much
why why why is why would it be shameful
if junior seau died because he was
having difficulty motional time or were
he was in a tough state or he was
suffering from mental illness um I read
an article yesterday on by a sports
writer I think who meant well and I
think his message was correct he wrote
an article about we don't really know
these athletes he said you know I cover
these athletes and
um you know you can't know them but then
he gave a bunch of examples of athletes
who had done bad things like we don't
know them and you know I'd this running
back ended up being bested on a cocaine
bust I thought he was a nicest guy but
he had a cocaine bust and somebody else
was taken away from this other crime
everyone was crimes and then there was
junior sale as if so what junior seau
had done his implication is was shameful
or morally weak and I know that I'm sure
he did not mean that I'm sure he was
meaning it as you just can't know and
all these things but but I i think you
know there i'm sure there were many
different reasons many different things
that contributed to junior Seau's death
and he was a complex guy and a really
good guy mean easy you know he was and
and and that's what people can't make
the kinect ago he was a really good guy
how can he kill himself those are not
mutually exclusive you know that you can
be a really good guy or a really good
woman and kill yourself and you can love
your family and you can love your
friends and still kill yourself yes you
were in a difficult state um but that
does not make you any less of a good
person and I was you know a friend of
mine said after seeing the film and I
guess I hadn't thought this way so I
didn't realize maybe how much some a lot
of people feel a little bit but he said
before he saw the movie he always
thought of people who killed themselves
as selfish he sort of thought in the in
the times that had happened in his life
he thought what kind of what a jerk like
how could that person do that what a
jerk and somebody even says that an
interview in the movie we don't wanted
what an idiot right um but he said after
the movie not long after he saw the
movie a friend of his committed suicide
and he said for the first time he
understood that that she wasn't a jerk
for doing this right she was in pain and
this occurred and it's a terrible
tragedy and and we all wish that she
would have been been able to talk to
someone and been able to work through it
um but she was not doing it to show
anyone else or two to teach a lesson to
anyone you know um she was doing it for
her own personal reasons and and junior
say oh could be a great person who
people love and he could still kill
himself it does happen and now that now
the thing is hopefully for his family
his friends and his fans to to still
celebrate him until
what we was that the two to remember who
this guy was and to to think of him not
only on the football field but also the
guy you know like me um loved going to
beach every day lived across the street
from the beach and he went the water and
he swam and you know that happy guy yes
he died of suicide I don't know what it
made you happier if you had gotten hit
by a truck you know like like why is it
that that that now just everything else
gets wiped away I say on the website and
have said other places that you know we
don't think of George Washington as the
president to you know died of a throat
infection and we don't think of of
Albert Einstein as the physicist who
died of an aneurysm but if either one
had killed themselves that would have
been that would have been the headline
that's all we'd remember George
Washington was the president who
committed suicide and that's the way it
goes you know you die that way that's
that's how we're going to define you and
that's a ridiculous way to define
someone a ridiculous no you know I and I
I know people don't do it out of malice
but but think about it you know yes they
people died in all sorts of weird ways
might you know we've created a wonderful
backdrop here to really get into talk
about you know making this film I mean
when you started when you started with
this film you know you had the idea of
like okay this is kind of what i want to
do here but i thought yeah i mean you
had no money you had no crew you didn't
have that the people you were going to
film and you know that you're going to
do subjects that you're going to put in
the film so how did it start to come
together well i think the really
important thing was once i decided to
make the movie the movie was going to
get made and that is that makes the
difference it wasn't well if i get
funding or if I you know if I get enough
the celebrities attached that I can
interview then I'll do it it was I'm
making this movie now if I make this
movie by myself um that means what's the
first thing I got to do I got to get a
camera fine I gotta learn how to use
that camera better but I will make it by
myself um because I want it to get made
and once I did that one by one people
said alright let me be a part of this
jay lafayette is my director photography
really good DP you can make a lot of
with a lot of people anytime he wants
but he knew that I was committed to it
he was interested in the subject I think
he wanted to do something interesting
and challenging so okay he's in now two
of us pushed forward right the mac emic
comes to me as a producer and says you
know all right I'm in I this is
something that's important to me I'd
like to learn more about the subject I
believe in what you're doing find three
people Fiona Walsh who I didn't even
know that well great line producer she
shows up at a restaurant one day a
friend had told you know we were meeting
at the overland cafe our production
meetings we're like over you know five
our coffees over you know at overland
cafe they hated us oh we tipped really
well we did tip really well I promise
but um you know Fiona showed up and
here's someone who you know it works all
the time there's no reason she Stig
months off to this movie but for
whatever reason what was going on in her
life right then told her I want to do
this this is now this is important to me
too and you do it is you know the the
hands on the rubber tree plant right but
but but it kept growing because everyone
one by one said we are making this movie
and the most important thing to me then
in doing this was this movie will be
made and not only will be made it will
be seen because I now I owe that to
everyone else I have made this promise
to them they have all come on without
doing any money anything else now this
movie has to be made I think if I if it
had been just me maybe a month of jus
downline maybe I would've been like oh I
failed like everything I thought was
going to happen was going to happen
right but but because now there were
people involved well I got to do
something and so it became a great
lesson in everything fell apart no
interviews we thought we'd have weren't
there locations we thought we'd be at
weren't there you know equipment doesn't
work or sound I can't make it you know
all the things that everyone goes
through with independent film but it was
this is getting done tomorrow tomorrow
is a shoe today so how are we going to
make this happen how are we you know how
do we facilitate the day to be the best
day we can and the things that got
discovered we're better than what we
then what we had planned um you just
have to give in to that and and ride the
wave that what I did it documentary
years back sort of fluffy documentary
where I talked to a lot of big wave
surfers about what's it like when you go
under you know
a 50 foot wave and every one of them
said you just gotta relax let go um that
if you fight it you'll die but if you
just let go and just let the wave take
you where it needs to take you you'll be
okay and we let this film take us where
it wanted to take us and it meant that
yes I had a quarry I the hip-hop
choreographer who I thought was going to
show up with all these sort of
20-something hotshot dancers and the
first day of rehearsal she showed up the
you know a bunch of teenagers which if I
had known ahead of time I've been like
oh good lord no we're not going to do
like that's this is a weird Jax
efficient well those kids were much
better than anyone I could have asked
for in the business you know and and and
over and over that happened where were
we there's a scene again that sort of
more intense scene I was talking about
with with the two clowns um where I'm
staging i'm doing a staging of a piece
and i didn't know them well i only knew
one of them sort of a little we had done
like a photo shoot with Roger um and he
said well there's this other woman
jessalyn she's really talented she might
be willing to do it and timing wise
people I thought I might use weren't
available and we showed up and jessalyn
like was like one step away from walking
out like not because of anything bad on
her side but it was a weird scene it was
late at night in an almost deserted
warehouse a really cool space actually
downtown but uh but I kind of cold and
drafty warehouse and we had been filming
all day and we didn't have a lot of time
and they didn't know what was going on
and I was like okay we're gonna stage it
we're gonna you know restage my mom
suicide ready action and and Jesslyn was
I think seriously thinking about leaving
but she stuck around and she gave an
unbelievable performance and if I had
had a budget and if I had had time I
might have been able to say that night
oh you know what it's late and Jesslyn
baby isn't totally feeling it because
it's a little weird and and maybe we
should just reschedule right but we
didn't we push forward and she gave an
extraordinary performance and so did
Roger and and I and I learned something
very important for future work because I
try to control things a lot of times and
I learned that you know um just let it
take you where it's going to take you
beep make your plans be prepared
you know have all sorts of contingency
stuff ready but then when it happens
just let it happen like don't try and
you know cling you know cling to your
original plan cuz you'll you'll sink
yeah well uh another YouTube video i was
watching the other day was of therapists
Virginia City r she's a great talk she
talks a lot about family issues and she
says it's not what happens to us in life
it's how we cope so what I noticed from
the documentary is you seem to cope
incredibly well maybe this was just in
front of the camera but I just to say I
couldn't send you some sources that
might disagree okay all right I will go
back for them I'm sure they'll enjoy it
certifiable okay but what I saw in the
video though excuse me in your film was
that you were a survivor and and I could
see this you know full steam ahead this
movies being made and that you took
yourself out of yourself and your own
problems and you interview these other
people whether they were survivors of
suicide or people that have lost people
and I'm wondering is this something then
and I think we're you've already alluded
to it that this was a learned trait for
you this is not something that you were
born with being this sort of the show
must go on and and carrying forward well
I think the show must go on has been
something that's been a part of me for a
long time but I think there's two
different things I I ran a small theater
company in New York for many many years
and we did weird performance art we
would call we sort of build ourselves as
Monty Python meets Merce Cunningham it
was a cross between weird dark sketch
comedy and modern dance so hot and we
would perform in sewers and on the sides
of buildings and in crazy spaces and I
at times the company would have a
majority people in the company didn't
speak English thank spoke Italian and
Japanese and Dutch and other things but
not english so i would have to stage
pieces in other languages but that made
it better so but the interesting thing
was in new york and small theatre which
I did for many years there always had to
be hey things are going to happen like
you know life's going to get weird and
you just kind of do the best you can but
when I came to Los Angeles and I started
working in more commercial television
then it became I lost that a little bit
of that sense of of hey let it happen
because you have budgets then you have a
crew
and you have a staff and you have all
these people so you go know we we will
control it we will make you know no we
control the day and you and we planned
this so this is what we're shooting you
know like and you think that you think
you have control and you really don't
but and you make something a little
worse I'm in some ways a bigger budget
sometimes will make you make worse art
because you because you come in with
your preconceived notion and you have
enough money to just jam whatever you
thought you were going to do down you
know make it happen and then put it up
and you're like there it's done we got
it done um but now even when i do now i
find as i am embarking again on more
sort of commercial television work ah
that that that spirits that i had in New
York that works so well on the film also
works even in larger budget stuff that
you still should embrace the unusual the
unexpected and and you know let it let
it happen try it out you know the
biggest mistake that I made when I
thought when I became a professional
right when you become you and you when
you you know join DGA and you say oh you
know now I'm I'm no longer an
independent artist right I'm now a very
accomplished person was that um i
decided to try to do things that i
thought other people might like and I
tried to and I would play it safe I
found myself playing things really safe
um you know we get we again we did it um
but but I didn't trust my instincts my
gut instincts and it made me I'm really
frustrated and it made mediocre work and
it made me a sort of mediocre director
um and so this dome really helped bring
me back to the idea that for better or
worse if you hire me for a project or if
it's my project we have to go with my
instincts and go with what whether I
think something's funny or not funny or
whether I think something's interesting
or not interesting like that's why you
brought me here and and I don't think
that sometimes my employers were telling
me that I shouldn't use my instincts I
was doing I was censoring myself because
you go like oh well there are a lot of
people who do this right and and you
know will they all seem to do it a
different way what i realize is hey you
know everybody should have a different
way you should you know you
you should embrace your your oddness and
and if somebody doesn't want you they'll
stop hiring you you know um but yeah I I
so I was prepared small theatre prepared
me well for independent film they are
very they are close close they're not
just cousins they're brother and sister
you know um I when I was in I don't
think he'll my I won't say his name but
a a good friend of mine who is a very
accomplished and very well respected
director in the theater um I was out
doing a appearance in Pennsylvania and
it was at a small college and I was out
at his house he has a place out there
and in the morning the film that I was
supposed to be staging her me the film
was supposed to be on a campus but it
the room hadn't been rent you know indie
film right that they didn't have the
room they were supposed to have so there
was nowhere to show it so the student
group who deranged it was like well
we're going to show it in a sorority in
like a living room somewhere so I'm busy
on 19 with a 19 year old sorority girl
on the phone like trying to book you
know book my film and I'm writing down
stuff and this director who I tell you
is has already have gotten Lifetime
Achievement Awards and is a very
well-recognized theatre director Amen
theater does not pay money right I'm
writing the instructions on the back of
his food stamps application and and
showed it to him and we're like this is
the meeting of independent film and
independent theatre writing instructions
to screen your film somewhere they don't
want you on someone else's food stamp
application you know and so theatre
prepared me well for ND there's no
question about that and and also i think
that there's another similarity theatre
and dance i also come from the dance
world something I love about dancers is
that no one becomes a dancer to be fast
there's doesn't happen right yeah there
are you know name how many dancers you
actually know their names right so
people become dancers because they want
to dance um and because they want to be
a part of that world and that that
everything about their experience in
that room and on that stage makes it
worth it right and that's why you go
into independent film there there that
the only reason to go into independent
film is because you have to say what
you're you want to say because you want
to be in that room because you want to
be working with those people because
like
dance if you're doing in a pit of film
the odds are you are not going to make
money off of this and you are not going
to to be famous even even though it is a
movie you know as as many of your guests
and you guys you know can well attests
you'll be writing stuff on the back food
stamps right but that's okay that but
that's okay usually yeah yeah yeahs base
I'd love that well I how long was the
production that's the film you know we
the first interview we did was with
Judith uh and probably the major part of
shooting did not take that long we
probably shot the vast majority of it in
about three months because we didn't any
money like we could only afford so many
shoots post-production was much longer
um gala yasunaga was my editor who's
amazing and if you look her up she's
done all sorts of great indie films
she's also my next door neighbor that's
the only way I got her was that the
commute was fantastic uh-huh you gave
her the parking space yeah exactly well
can I totally lied to get her and
hopefully she won't watch this but dumb
she's you know I uh I knew of her I mean
I knew her work and she is next door her
husband also was very successful
filmmaker and and and she said I thought
well maybe if i ask gail i said gail do
you uh do you know any young editors who
might be interested in working on a film
and and you know doing a little
independent thing and it's not really
gonna pay and you know and she said well
we know what about me and I said oh you
know i i'd love to have you but you know
i can't pay you your raped and I can't
you know she said well let me let me
look at you know some of the footage
didn't just take a look at it my brought
over a couple things I knew were pretty
good and the next day she came back and
said like I'll do it right um and so was
it was great but but I have no idea why
I brought up Gail right now I just
totally lost my dreams long but uh uh
but yes so I you asked me a good
question and I totally forgot I was
talking about Gail this is what happens
folks well you're not the length of the
production you said forget thank you
thank goodness my keepers here um the
Edit process was much longer than I was
used to because I when it comes to being
on in LA my vast amount of experiences
in television so you knock out an hour
two hours and you know five weeks six
weeks maybe maybe eight or ten weeks and
so that part of the process was a
learning experience for me because it
was much slower but not because Gail was
just so into the details and was able to
find things that I never would have
found with this movie I was able to
bring a sort of beauty and maturity to
it that you know I would never have
gotten you know I would have to slay
them things together and then vikki rose
sampson came on to do post to do sound
who she's done you know little films
like Star Wars and Donnie Darko and
things like that um and so I thought
again like sound mix right sound mix to
me and television is like three or four
days like you know maybe a week maybe
maybe two if you're really getting crazy
but sound mix was like six weeks I was
like oh my god so posts full time
probably was nine months you know um so
so yeah I would say about a year and a
half probably from first interview to
absolute lock you know end up and that
was a lesson I'm really glad that I love
my film and that I love doing it and I
love watching it um that sounds very
vain but um I can't imagine not liking
the film you made and being stuck with
it for years like I'm going to spend
another I just got back from the road
going out and going to colleges and then
we have in the fall we're having a
festival called day of the living which
where we're going to invite theatre
company what we already have invited
some theatre companies dance companies
artists and filmmakers um to participate
in creating work thats in this in a sort
of spirit of our movie dealing with
mental illness and suicide so we're
going to do that festival the first week
of October and then I'm going to go back
out on the road but the movie RF our
sort of official premiere will be then
all everything up to now has been sneak
preview free sneak preview um and so I
will be with this movie for you know
close to three years by the time i'm not
you know on it somewhat full time I
don't know how you could make a movie um
that didn't matter to you I just I can't
imagine it you're with it for so long
which everyone out there is like
no of course idiot like everyone else is
filmmakers they'll get it right but I
didn't really understand this is my
first feature so so I had heard it you
know you're with a film for three years
but you really are with the film before
three years that's that's a man you guys
have been how long have you been working
on yours about 3 years 3 years Larry
still having a week's time as shown it
yet so yeah well I'm looking forward to
it have tickets gonna be great you know
and the subject that I know well as a
fast so as a long time actor who no
longer really I I that subject art
imitating life they were like that we
like to get your take on him when the
time comes Mike there though you know we
definitely get your take on it yeah yeah
um so what was the easiest part of
making the film well the easiest part
was that the film was going to get made
that that there was no back and forth
whether I was going to make that that um
and I think that sometimes people go
they spend years deciding oh is this the
right project is this the wrong product
and i guess i should say there was i did
start thinking about this movie about
three years before i made it so i guess
i'm lying in some sense I did postpone
it I have to say I had an agent again
when I was a big shot I had an agent who
wouldn't even say if I because I said oh
I want to make this documentary about
Souza is really important to me to talk
about my mom I'm gonna do always say I
didn't really know Judis story but I was
going to be about my mom and he wouldn't
even acknowledge he would almost look
away from me um and and not even
acknowledge that I'd said the words
documentary and suicide um uh he would
just go okay anyway and then push on to
some other project so um but I think the
easiest part probably or the most fun
part for me um were the days of shooting
I really am but I loved interviewing
people for this movie and I loved
working with people I love this movie is
about when you get depressed everything
gets sort of gray right and and you sort
of lose your spark the world becomes a
sort of mushy and and for me whether
you're in a rehearsal room of their in a
dance room whether you
writers room of comics like creating
work whether you're you know whether
you're interviewing someone who you're
interested in that's fascinating um and
and I wanted to show in this movie I
figured if if suicide is is something
that takes something away from the world
on all of these creative entities and
people sharing in this movie we're
adding back to this world if you want to
talk about the energy rejected met
before like all this positive stuff was
coming out of it so every day we shot
was fascinating for me and was was fun
it was fun to see people in their
element I love to see a choreographer
working with dancers I'd love to see a
comic working with writers I love to
hear someone sharing a story that's
important to them so that to me I love
being on that set um and and that was a
lot of fun but everything about this
movie was fun there was frustration
there was challenges there was you know
you know days of what am i what are we
doing but it was a genuinely it was a
genuinely fun experience and one that
that was incredibly important for me to
do it at the time that I did it so I
don't think that there was any it was
fascinating for me even at four in the
morning doing a sound mix and being
stuck on the same q over and over you
know like it still was they would still
the movie that I wanted to make every
frame in this movie is exactly as I
wanted it to be and some people may not
like the movie and so then they may well
be right but there is nothing in this
movie that I didn't want um so so the
easy part was the movie um the hundred
part now i think is you know in
listening to your you're winning your
podcast a couple of weeks ago when they
was talking about you know 35 to 45
thousand you know films features made
every year 600 to Sundance 202 or know
600 in the on the circuit 202 Sundance
40 get funding right um I'm glad I
didn't know that before I made a film I
still would have ate it but I might have
been a more sad probably the thing now
the hard part of this film is thinking
well people may not see it I know that
we've already affected people i know
that um we've already if no more people
saw it now i know that it still was
worth
um but I truly in my heart feel that
that we did make a film worth watching
and did make an entertaining film and
one that can really help um and I don't
know how many people are going to see it
because we don't have distribution where
it we we have joked but it's not really
a joke that if you have 10 people in a
couch I'll come show you the movie I I
have gone you know whether it is
sororities in Pennsylvania I have gone
large and small I've shown it in living
rooms and I've shown it in big theaters
and and that's great but it's hard
because you do go oh I'm showing this to
or you shove a theater of 200 people or
200 seats and 40 people because people
are scared to death of the movie so I
guess the hard part will be letting it
go if we didn't feel we got it out there
but the great thing is we never thought
we'd make money so in the end will
distribute it you know for free well go
just throw discs into everybody's
mailbox i'll just get randomly you know
drive around the city chucking discs out
you know if need be but it is as you
know and as any of your viewers and
listeners know uh you know it's a tough
challenge i mean i don't know i can't
swear to you this is a terrible thing
for some without distribution to say but
i don't know if i went to the multiplex
and i saw don't change the subject to
movie about suicide I don't know if I'd
go see it maybe but maybe I wouldn't so
I get it I get wipeout someone's not
like boy we're going to make a mint on
this um I think the only way that
probably you know we'll get distribution
is if somebody wants to distribute
something that they think is genuinely
good and can genuinely make the world a
better place how many distributors feel
that way well you tell me you know
there's still better than I do we just
had a conversation just last week with
it with a filmmaker named dean peterson
who has an independent film called
incredibly small which he took on the
festival circuit for you know a couple
years and then he finally said you know
what we're just gonna release it for
free on vimeo and he's had he's had
tremendous success that way with with
almost 40,000 views just in a couple
weeks on vimeo so yeah you know the day
you know you get your film scene but i'm
just wondering you know you can it's
easy to hear your passion for this film
for the subject matter you know you're
talking a little bit know about the
making and about people seeing it how
important has it been to you to sort of
take this film that's so personal to you
and share it with that live audience
well again coming from a theater
background you know as a theater guy I
like I know what know where am I more
comfortable than standing in front of a
crowd talking about myself you know the
vanity of the director right so um and
about my life like there's a iluv iluv
engaging with an audience I love hearing
what they have to say and talking to
them I don't I try not to get up and
make a speech I try to really to to
interact and to talk and to dig into it
right I love that so that you know has
been incredibly important to me and I
think again the movie i think has gone
over well in places where I wasn't but I
think if I'm there there's there is a
context to it that helps um because I
think it's hard you know you're on a
college campus some of these college
campuses will show this movie like at
lunch with people like in line you know
getting her satellites and stuff you
know they'll show it whatever i'm going
to got Boston for you know for you know
showing it but sometimes if i'm there at
least i'm able to say hey here's why I
made this movie I'm a real person this
is important to me don't be scared stay
in your seats like you know it's gonna
be okay and again just keep them there
and then they go oh right this is you
know but oh this is pretty good um so so
yeah it's incredibly important I wish
that I could could really do it full
time you know just keep going on the
road i would i would just do a little
road show um but you know it's expensive
so so I I did a couple of months I mean
our thing was we would we would give
sort of this 68 month period from
january on we were sort of like all
right we'll see how we do in festival
but but i'm not going to sit around and
wait you know to get accepted we'll take
it out semi theatrical you know get it
to as many places for free as we can and
then after that if we don't get if we
don't get something out of festivals
we'll just start you know we'll continue
it but raise it to the level of going
into public theater's and that kind of
thing and and you know right now we've
been pretty roundly ignored by festival
so so the next step will be back on the
road i'll be back on the road in
September and take it out probably
the year and who knows I mean the nice
thing about this film is it's a bit of
an evergreen it's not specific I mean
it'd be great if people stopped killing
so I'd be very happy to never have to
show the film because everyone's happy
and but it is a film that we could show
in 10 years and that I could still go
and be a part of I mean you know I of
course i'm looking forward to new
projects to I'm not just going to be the
you know the suicide guy but um but yeah
it's very gratifying to share it with
audiences and to get feedback and to you
know and and especially young audiences
I just there's that that great it's a
great age 22 when you're in college like
the just the amount of possibility and
the way of viewing the world there's a
there's a there's almost a great
arrogance to being young you know and
and hopefully people are able to keep
that all through their light but there's
nothing like a college student
challenging you even if they disagree
with you there's nothing I get 20 year
old being like well let me tell you
about it filled I probably gave myself
here but I remember them film scared
straight so and that's timeless you know
but what are you doing specifically to
drum up press aside from the whole
college tour thing you said that sort of
the indie film scene is retreating a
little bit from it what else you doing
you're reaching out to the therapeutic
recovery I'm not to be indie film seems
retreating I think they just don't care
they're sitting somewhere over there you
know having a cappuccino um but uh and
and don't get me wrong like I I love ND
felt I mean you know I am I was rear
doughnuts I love it so I you know I sit
sadly outside their door saying oh I'd
love to come in but um but I you know so
so I'm not in any way mocking the
community and I get why Sundance doesn't
want a little foam like ours um but they
made a mistake but we are the festival
that we're doing in the fall hopefully
will also garner some press attention
we've also gotten a lot of the thing
about the subject is there are people
who are very passionate about there are
critics are very passionate about it
we've gotten very good feedback from a
lot of people in the press saying yes we
want to do a story as soon as you
distribute the film as soon as you put
it anywhere will cover it and we've
already gotten some early reviews and
some very nice things said by critics
Britain they seem to really like a sting
gelen but um so we hope that our
festival day of the living
October will be a kind of focused point2
to get some of that press coverage
simultaneous press coverage and and we
will show the film in Los Angeles of
that first week in October concurrent
with the festival and what we want for
those who are listening seat watching is
I would love to have some short films
two to three minute films to run before
our film to challenge some other
filmmakers to put their spin on this
subject whether they do it in a humorous
manner to do it in a non traditional
manner in some way we'd love to we're
inviting other filmmakers to to submit
to us to go to our website my email is
on the website you know Mike it don't
change the subject auto work get in
touch make something I'm sharing this we
look at the festival the same way we
looked at the film which is we're going
with the wave there are some artists i
know that are going to be a part of it
it's all going to be under one roof the
dance the theater the art hanging on the
walls will all be under one roof so
it'll be sort of a theatrical happening
right and and just down the street will
be the movie so so it will all channel
um 21 and beyond that there are there
are there are definitely media outlets
that are interested in talking about
suicide so our movie helps them to do
that you you run into again that's
contagion argument so some media places
are really enthusiastic others are
terrified of saying the word suicide but
but we we've gotten some coverage I
think we'll get a fair amount more
because i think it is it is a
life-and-death subject and that isn't
why I chose I didn't think like man this
is it we know we it's we've got a
captive audience but it is a really
important subject and one that isn't
covered that much there are movies about
suicide out there but not that many for
a reason because people are terrified
why would you make a movie nobody wants
to see well Mike we appreciate you
reaching out to us and sharing your
story and in this movie with us I mean
this is this conversation has just been
really meaningful to me just just
kicking back and just listen and you go
through all this and why would you just
want to thank you for that yeah and I
think it's great to that you've made
this film because there
are so many people that don't want to
reach out to the medical community or
their families or whatever about suicide
but what if they Google something in the
privacy of their own dorm room like you
said and are able to find a resource
like this and it changes their opinion
and it's really a film to about the
celebration of life so it's not it's not
too scary I think there are parts that
it does take you there a little bit but
all in all it doesn't leave you with
that feeling and I think you've done a
beautiful job well I really appreciate
that and I hope that people you know if
you go to our website you know it don't
change the subject out of work there are
resources there are a lot of mental
health resources on there there are a
lot of funny stories from the movie
there are a lot of clips there are a lot
of things for whether you're a dorm room
or your living room or wherever you know
go on there get on our mailing list and
follow the journey with us and or join
it you know there I hope that there's
someone out there watching this that
thinks oh that that's important to me or
that sounds interesting emails me and
joins the team that that you know what I
would they like to work at the living
festival great do they want to have me
come to their city I want me to sit on
your couch will show you the movie I
will do it like like I would love it I
look forward to meeting the newest
members of our team and an innocent and
I really appreciate you guys being a
part of this and helping to to give some
exposure to the movie and I also really
appreciate what you're doing with your
website because I know how challenging
that is to have something that that is
ongoing you know it's one thing to it's
a good idea and you go like I will throw
up some interviews right but to
continually address this this
challenging field that we work in and
this field that that you know talking
about feeling suicidal that you know can
really put you down sometimes and and
and make you wonder if you've made good
choices you guys are there as a great as
a great voice and a great source of
information I've learned a lot from from
your site most of which you know some of
which I was like why did I make a film
but but it's fun to see both your
journey with your film and the journey
that so many filmmakers doing and I know
there are so many people out there like
me who are just as fashion of a war
passionate about their projects and
that's great I look forward to seeing
their films too you know I look forward
to that and and however they somebody
wants to get in touch with me and say
well how did you do this how did you get
to colleges how did you do whatever
great get in touch i'll get you know
i'll get back to you I don't have that
much going on in my life awesome okay
we've been speaking with filmmaker mike
Stutz about his documentary don't change
the subject for more on Mike in his film
you know please visit don't change the
subject org as he said get in contact
with him makes you know you know those
emails there you can email yeah email
there on twitter it is me suicide blows
suicide blows which I love that twitter
handle and there you will get my random
odd sense of humor array it's not just a
it's not just suicide messages their way
you'll find out who I am you'll find out
how I deal with stressful situations
certainly political musings you know you
can also find is the facebook page under
don't change the subject um then I MTB
there are my stats yeah long was two
credits strict so yeah well thank you
again Mike and thanks to a great railing
for introducing you to us them yeah Greg
failing a good talk about one of the
nicest guys in the business right like
Greg feeling those out there he hooked
us up but I drag is one of those people
that talk about everything he does comes
from a positive place and if we all
could be so lucky 22 to come from where
Greg comes from the world would be a
better place and I have a feeling you
guys are the same so it seems quite much
like that thank you yeah well great
talking to you guys